cannot wait hey mercedes the search has
started for the next german baby already
but there's not a whole lot of time to
enter
yeah that is trending this morning the
last day to apply
is monday so if you have a little one
that is no older than 48 months old and
has an infectious giggle
your child could be the next star now
the winner of
the photo contest will be featured on
gerber's social media accounts
and their marketing campaigns they'll
also receive
25 000 in cash now if you
think your baby has what it takes all
you have to do is upload your favorite
photos and video of your little one
showing off their personality now by the
way john alex i know you don't have kids
but since we're talking about babies oh
boy
i wanted to see what a little john and a
little alex would look like so
we did a little magic uh i put john with
britney spears this is what a baby with
john and britney spears would look like
so adorable right yeah it's uh
yeah i'm sure something gerber is
tripping over themselves to try and get
their hands on that yeah what about alex
okay um oh no
it looks like john from the toyota
dealership
yeah who is playing these matchups
together there's no way brad pitt's
could ever look
anything like that i don't know i think
they're
adorable yeah they are they're yeah
we'll go with
you that mercedes i hear we're out of
time unfortunately with you but thank
you we look forward to seeing your baby
mash up
i'm so sad i'll see you guys soon have a
great morning